his two starts have been pretty good he
went uh five innings against miami went
five and a third against the dodgers
held them to one run on four hits uh
didn't give up a hit until the fourth
inning in that ball game against the
dodgers dylan carlson is hitting second
in the lineup carlson for the series one
out of 12. three walks a double a run
scored and an rbi let it fly into the
pool
let it fly into the pool
just tow
that's what i'm talking about let it rip
let it fly
go into the pole
a home run his first since the 7th of
april down in miami
dylan carlson with his fourth home run
of the year and it's one to nothing
cardinals in the first well he earned a
pitch in the inner half of the plate
because he took a pitch on the outer
half
the pitch was up and in and he was able
to
open up the body on the inside pitch and
get the bat head to it and got it right
on the good part of the bat and sent it
out and nice at bat for dylan carlson
and kk gets the call today four road
starts he's owen two with a 386 era on
the road overall these one and two this
season
the pitch is bounced high toward the
third baseman rondon gets it throws and
just gets him at first what a strong
throw by jose rondon to retire escobar
who was running hard all the way it's
rare they ever uh dust off andrew kisner
the backup catcher but he gets a start
with molina on the bench andrew kisner
swings and lines it into center field
hit hard and he goes past martin to the
wall
rondon is on his way around third base
he's trying to score the throw to the
plate too late
the cardinals have a two-nothing lead an
extra base hit by catcher andrew kisner
gives andrew his second rbi of the year
it's a good swing right here he stayed
back he's having a little bit of trouble
getting on top of the ball lately and
there you go
make the adjustment
backspin line drive it just goes to the
wall and
[Applause]
watch out i don't know if anyone was at
third base right there he could have
kept running
first triple of the year for ahmed and
that'll bring up la castro with a runner
at third and two men out there's a
basement for loco diamondbacks on the
board
two out triple and the two out single
brings in the run make it two to one so
tim lacastro with a line single to the
left for an rbi and the diamondbacks are
on the board a two odd single two out
rally all the way
triple by ahmed with two outs
and he weighed it back nicely on this
curveball here's marty popped up to
goldie's first time up right around the
mound area
sends one deep to left center can tell
martay
that's his first homer since april
second and we are tied at two
martinez third of the year
2-2
boy was that ball punished
i mean that was a full swing that looked
like he knew what was coming the whole
time really he kissed it out of here
good to see him muscling up here from
the right side
no doubter to left center field to tie
this game
april 2nd has been its previous homer
and we're all leaving at two all right
let's see what cattell can do with the
bases loaded and two men out in the tie
game here on the fourth inning
bounces it to third it gets byron down
reddick is home here comes peacock hayes
in there
martay delivers a two-inch single of the
diebacks have the lead four to two
battling it back by cattell that time
tries to come back with the slider to
the back
top door grounder gets underneath the
glove of rondon down there at third base
at peacock he doesn't have to worry
about anybody running up his back
[Music]
two run single with two outs four could
tell makes it 4-2 diamondbacks he's
knocked in three
and arizona trying to snap a 13-game
losing skid here today that's swung on
and grounded to sosa who backhand
stumbles gets up throws and got him wow
a lot going on on that play but walker
three times has hit the ball to sosa and
he's over three a great play
off balance gathered and made the throw
outfield a little bit
oh he did he dropped it i didn't realize
he dropped it right away
that is incredible awareness
all right here is the top of the order
and josh rojas josh is over two of the
walk
dieback's trying to add to their 4-2
lead here in the sixth inning hits it
right at sosa
the castro halfway home
they got him hung up
the whole cardinal team is on the run
down he collides with the infielder
and we're still going here and they
finally get him at home
he ran into ron doan and now he's going
to make a point with las diaz
right there i think last year as you saw
him wave safe immediately he felt like
tim lacastro went way out of his way to
make contact right there with ron doan
now let's see if carson has got two hits
in the ball game two for three can come
through here ball four walking nothing
close to the plate grunt comes in haven
smith rojos goes to third down to sega
goes marta into first base goes kelly
he'll never get an easier run bandit in
a basis loaded walk five two
diamondbacks basketball they get her now
with the bases loaded one out one in
here on the six
and a ground ball knocked down by
goldsmith to the second baseman they've
got no play
infield hit by escobar run scores at 6-2
diamondbacks
i'm on the maze goldie even got a glove
on that ball to knock it down deflected
to the uh sega basement carpenter but he
had no play anywhere really wanted to
take advantage here and really open this
one up pitch on the way to walker little
looper trying to get down then that
drops into short left
katella's home they will stop carson
and it's 7-2
toy lavello took matt peacock out of the
game
and only 78 pitches hoping to blow up
the inning and he's certainly done that
three runs home 7-2 and here's reddick
who has doubled and singled he's two for
three there's another floater out there
come on gets in there
carson scores they'll stop escobar make
it eight to two
now the banner will be ahmed with the
bases loaded he's the ninth man to ban
to the setting swings on the ground down
to third rondo scouted steps on third
throws low to first by goldsmith escobar
is home
nine to two he had plenty of time but he
skipped it over there and goldie
couldn't help him out
another round and nine to two our score
yep that should have been the end of the
inning right there and arizona trying to
snap a 13-game losing skid here today
center field can tell marta
and kiss that losing straight goodbye
chori lavello the winner
his 304th win as d-max manager
and the losing streak
is over